there's big business and more my country
earns a ton of money and more sodas
yours so to Sweden the home of the
nobles and Sweden I'm sorry is a big
arms dealer it's a contradiction and
it's something that we have to start
having an open conversation about I
think in my country whenever you talk
about cutting the so-called defense
budget you get pushback from the many
companies that are part of the
military-industrial complex which is by
the way we're given to us by general
dwight d eisenhower it is not a hippie
word when he last spoke in 54 he told
americans to be where the
military-industrial complex to worry
about the fact that the u.s. now wanted
to standing military to worry about the
fact that there are you know factories
and industry that you know the defense
industry to worry about that instead
there have been many times in my country
when the department of defense will give
its budget to Congress for example and
they have cut out programs they want to
close military bases they recently the
f-35 a new fighter jet they wanted that
cut they don't need it however the
Congress people voted money for the f-35
because it was jobs and I think what
kind of nation
wants to promote jobs and industries
that kill other people and wrap it in
the flag of patriotism so I try to
unravel that mythology a little bit